[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardina y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente El
magacín quincenal de France 24 en el que
les acercamos las historias de medio
oriente a América Latina Esto es lo que
veremos en nuestro primer programa de
hoy
Irán está asumido en la mayor ola de
protestas desde 2019 que iniciaron con
la muerte de la joven macza mini bajo
custodia de la policía de la moral iraní
por supuestamente llevar mal puesto el
jillab las manifestaciones se han
extendido por todo el país dejando
decenas de muertos y por primera vez son
las mujeres jóvenes quienes lideran las
marchas analizamos lo que está
sucediendo con nuestra invitada y Líbano
sufre su peor crisis económica desde la
guerra civil que terminó en 1990 la
libre alibanesa se ha desplomado en más
del 95%, por lo que los disturbios
frente a los bancos son constantes
frente al colapso Financiero en el país
algunos comerciantes le están dando un
nuevo uso a las desvalorizadas monedas y
en Jerusalén del este un grupo de
activistas vestidos de payasos hacen que
los menores palestinos olviden la
violencia diaria en los territorios
ocupados por Israel a través de las
risas
iniciamos en Irán la indignación por el
asesinato de la joven de 22 años maxa
mini después de ser detenida por la
policía de la moral por llevar el velo a
media caballera desató una oleada de
protestas masivas las jóvenes iraníes se
lanzaron a las calles mostrando su
rechazo a la imposición del hillab ante
la brutal represión de las autoridades
de la república islámica que deja casi
un centenar de Muertos según el gobierno
y más de 150 según las organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos pese a todo Las jóvenes
han perdido el miedo alzar sus voces
ante el abuso a sus derechos por parte
del régimen iraní Y es que el 93% de los
manifestantes son menores de 25 años
para analizar la situación de las
mujeres en Irán tenemos con nosotras a
ver entorcharo que ya es politóloga y
feminista musulmana Muchas gracias por
estar en France 24 Belén lo primero
huelen las protestas inician por el
asesinato de una joven de la región del
kurdistán iraní por agredir los cánones
de vestimenta de la república islámica
que nos dice Esto del detonante de las
manifestaciones
bueno claramente que
pertenece a la región del kurdistán esto
es una nación que ha quedado sin
territorio a raíz de los diferentes
procesos de colonización que ha vivido y
que tiene en detonante toda esta región
no así como las mujeres palestinas
tienen la situación de vivir la doble
colonización
actualmente Lo mismo sucede con las
mujeres kurdas y Esto va ha hecho un
caldo de cultivo para toda la situación
de la protesta social recordemos que el
pueblo kurdo dentro de lo que es Irán
también está reclamando más derechos por
ciudad ciudadanía está siempre tiene una
batalla que dar con respecto a los
principales
principios ordenadores dentro de la
sociedad como toda nación que ha quedado
en en encerrona de de la colonización y
una nación sin territorio propio Belén y
cuál es el papel de las mujeres en la
sociedad iraníes existe una especie de
revolución inacabada para estas mujeres
de Irán
a ver las personas que estudiamos estos
temas sabemos que no es la primera vez
que ha sucedido existe muchísima agencia
lo que se dice agencia en ciencias
sociales es la capacidad de acción de
cualquier grupo social en este caso las
mujeres dentro de las protestas y los
reclamos
La Apuesta en debate sobre el tema de la
obligatoriedad del velo no es nueva en
Irán Solo que acá se combinan con otra
serie de factores
sociales de un malestar social de un
consenso que ya deja de ser consenso Sí
Dentro de una sociedad y este rol
fundamental y protagonista de las
mujeres dentro de la sociedad iraní
insisto como que no es nuevo ahí había
marchas organizadas los miércoles
el Día de las marchas de los pañuelos
blancos sí en donde se ponía en tela de
juicio
parte del colectivo de mujeres el debate
del uso obligatorio Como así
que tienen que es parte de su identidad
el uso del velo hay que decirlo y
aclararlo tiene un sentido polisémico sí
que no no es un único sentido ni
reduccionista tiene una multiplicidad de
sentidos y en esa multiplicidad de
sentidos se juegan también los sentidos
identitarios no solo los sentidos
religiosos los sentidos políticos y
también una lucha contra la colonización
que ha vivido este pueblo si
precisamente sobre este tema sobre el
debate interno sobre esta obligatoriedad
del velo también cuéntanos un poco Cómo
se ve desde fuera o sobre esta
precisamente obligatoriedad desde los
países occidentales y este doble
patriarcado que existe sobre las mujeres
en relación También mujeres del mundo
islámico
claro a ver claramente lo importante
sumar la herramienta de análisis a todo
esto y la espectacularización que se
hace a través del sentido
del colectivo mujer musulmana no hay una
espectacularización y una morbosidad con
respecto a este juego y En definitiva
Estas mujeres quedan encerradas en la
lógica de entre un patriarcado y otro y
esta batalla geopolítica se juega en el
cuerpo territorio femenino siempre no en
el uso del cuerpo es llamativo lo
hipócrita que suena también dentro de
las sociedades occidentales que suceden
con esas mujeres musulmanas cuando
llegan a territorio a territorio europeo
no que sucede con esa famosa libertad de
la que de la que tanto se habla
actualmente
sobre libertad entre comillas pongo
sobre las mujeres musulmanas y qué
sucede con las situaciones de
precariedad que viven las mujeres
musulmanas en territorio occidental y
qué conflictos trae esto no exigimos esa
libertad y esa toma de derechos desde
desde Qué mirada y qué sucede con esas
mujeres cuando están en territorio
occidental Sí precisamente Belén los
movimientos feministas occidentales se
han levantado en apoyo a las mujeres
iraníes pero crees que existe una visión
colonialista o cierta forma paternalista
cuando se trata de mostrar solidaridad
con las mujeres musulmanas también un
discurso como salvacionista cuando se
habla de la mujer el islam
absolutamente
creo que hay está teñido siempre
haciendo un juego de palabras hablamos
de correr el velo occidental que hay
cada vez que se habla de un colectivo de
mujeres con esta identidad religiosa así
como de las otras identidades religiosas
creo que los feminismos y hablo en
plural
deberían interpretar esto de un modo no
monolítico no hay un solo modo de
habitar El el la cuestión mujer en este
mundo y no hay un y no hay una sola
manera de dar esa lucha no claramente en
las diferentes mujeres alrededor del
mundo están dando sus batallas sus
protagonismos y teniendo sus agencias
propias su agenda propia y sus
principios ordenadores propios quedar en
sus propias sociedades creo
fundamentalmente que hay que acompañar
esta lucha pero
dándole el protagonismo que tienen las
mujeres iraníes en este caso no y es
fundamental acompañarles esta protesta
desde ese lugar cediendo ese
protagonismo porque si no estamos
nuevamente hablando de un etnocentrismo
cada vez que sucede alguna protesta
social de esta índole
Belén Muchísimas gracias por estar en
este primer programa de Expreso de
Oriente y por su análisis Muchas gracias
por haber estado en Francia 24
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes
y seguimos en Líbano porque debido a la
peor crisis económica desde la guerra
civil que terminó en 1990 la libre
alibanesa se ha desplomado en más del
95%, respecto al tipo oficial Desde que
la nación cayó en El colapso Financiero
hace tres años lo que ha generado
protestas constantes frente a los bancos
y es que los libaneses culpan al
despilfarro y a la corrupción Estatal de
la crisis ante la precaria situación
monetaria estás joyeras de trípoli
fabrican accesorios brazaletes y
collares con las monedas encontrando así
una manera de darle un uso útil sin que
a diferencia de su valor en el mercado
caigan en el olvido Esto es lo que nos
dicen
Es cierto que la moneda ya no tiene
valor porque ya no podemos comprar nada
con ella Pero sigue siendo muy valiosa
para nosotros y no queremos que se
pierda
es una parte de nosotros parte de
nuestras no queremos tirarla no queremos
olvidarla
y nos vamos hasta Jerusalén allí payasos
en Rebeldía una compañía circense con
orígenes en España completó una gira por
Jerusalén este y varias ciudades de
cisjordania con el fin de hacer frente a
la ocupación y la desigualdad israelíes
a través de la risa la iniciativa festic
Clown contó tanto con artistas españoles
como argentinos y colombianos en su
recorrido disfrutaron de Un Show ante
6000 personas en la urbe de nabús pero a
la vez fueron testigos deredadas de
soldados impedimentos en Checkpoints e
incluso tuvieron que Cancelar sus
últimos espectáculos debido a la
violencia en cisjordania de las últimas
semanas que deja decenas de Muertos
nuestros corresponsales Yanira Gómez
Muñoz y Federico cuevar venera
acompañaron a estos payasos Y esta es la
historia
israelí acaba de dejar a este grupo
circense sin sonido ni trapecios la
impedido cruzarlos desde cisjordania lo
cual estimula más a Iván Hoy no podemos
ni volar ni traer nuestros equipos de
sonido Entonces estamos recreando Bueno
estamos improvisando
Iván es la nariz roja mayor de payasos
en Rebeldía colectivo que nació en
Galicia y que luego en plena segunda
indifada renació como red internacional
de artistas
ya sea México el Sáhara occidental o
aquí en Jerusalén con sus giras festic
Clown combaten injusticias en este caso
la ocupación israelí en territorio
palestino
poner nuestra arte de nuestra carne
Nuestro esfuerzo y nuestro sudor al lado
de aquellos y aquellas que luchan contra
el sistema global de terror en cualquier
lugar del mundo llevamos el circo como
herramienta de construcción masiva como
herramienta de diversión masiva para a
través de la alegría podamos combatir el
miedo al día siguiente la parada es en
Belén en unión con el centro la allí
payasos fundo hace tres años la primera
escuela de circo en un campo de
refugiados palestinos hoy ensayan para
el festival pero a través del arte
también aprenden a superar obstáculos Y
empoderarse en equipo y hay que
improvisar día a día las rutinas y pasan
demasiadas cosas que no permiten tener
una continuidad como el agua no si
tienen agua un día así Un día no y no
saben si mañana van a tener quieren ir a
un lugar y no saben si se van a poder
trasladar o cuando van a llegar Por un
instante las redadas desaparecen de la
mente de los alumnos pese a actuar al
pie del muro erigido por Israel
Los Niños del Campo no tenían un espacio
Así que el circo se volvió un lugar para
hacer algo con energía que tienen es muy
importante que los niños vean que hay
otras cosas que pueden hacer con su
energía y lo aman López Esta vez sí los
trapecistas logran lucir sus acrobacias
el broche final de estos payasos que
luchan por un mundo más solidario con
armas que son tartas de nata y muertos
que son muertos de risa
llegamos al final de esta edición de
Expreso de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y los invito a enviar sus
comentarios a las redes sociales que
aparecen en sus pantallas y a seguir con
toda la información en nuestra página
web France 24.com continúen con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]